you didn't win the Nobel Prize the team
of bicep that led the bicep 2 didn't win
the Nobel Prize because of some
space dust that's right uh kick Schmutz
uh which one is the moon which one is
that one's the dust the space dust yep
what are we looking at so why why is
space dust the the villain of this whole
story well it's funny you know I wrote
these books and I don't know about you
but when you get all these books I'm
sure you get books people sending books
they always come in these dust jackets
right I was like what the hell is a dust
Jack like how much dust is raining down
at any moment I mean this is immaculate
this room is Russian tidiness but but in
a normal household how much dust is
raining down it's not not really part
until
I wrote a book and I realized you know
I'm writing a story about the origin of
the universe now the prologue you know
to the cosmos and dust is going to cover
this story it was actually it's actually
more a story about astrophysics and
cosmology than dust and this is the link
between
the cosmological and the astrophysical
so what does that mean so astrophysics
is broadly speaking the study of you
know physical phenomena manifest in the
heavens astronomical and phenomena
cosmology is concerned with the origin
Evolution composition of the universe as
a whole but it's not really concerned
with stars galaxies and planets per se
other than how they might help us
measure the Hubble constant the density
of the universe the neutrino content et
cetera
so we tend have a tendency to kind of
look a little bit you know they're like
not all astronomers or an
astrophysicists are equal they're all
equal but some are more equal than
others so we have kind of a Prejudice a
little Swagger right and cosmologists
are studying you know we're using
Einstein we're not using like you know
boltzmann or we're thinking of the
biggest possible pictures in so doing
you can actually become blinded to
otherwise obvious effects that people
you know would have not overlooked in
our case when we sought out the signal
we were using the photons that make up
this primordial heat bath that surrounds
the universe luckily only at three
degrees Kelvin approximately we're using
those as a type of film onto which
gravitational waves will reverberate it
make them oscillate preferentially in a
polarized way and then we can use our
polarized sunglasses but in the in the
microwave format to detect the
characteristic two-fold symmetry pattern
of under rotation that's the technical
way that we undergo it I mean there's a
lot more to it
um but there more than one thing that
can mimic exactly that signal first of
all when you look at the signal the
signal if inflation took place big if
but if it took place
the signal would be about one or two
parts per billion
of the CMB temperature itself
so a few Nano Kelvin the CMB is a few
kelman the signal from these B mods
would be a few Nano Kelvin it's
astonishing to think Penzeys and Wilson
1965 measured something that's a billion
times brighter and that was what 60
years ago it's called 60 years ago since
they discovered it Moore's Law you're
more expert now let's call it every two
years so you're talking about like 2 to
the 30th power doubling or something
like that at that so let's call 2 to the
20th something like that so that's like
only um uh 2 to the tenth is a as a as a
thousand all right correct my math I'm
wrong to the 20th is a million right to
the 30th is a billion so you we're
outpacing Moore's law in terms of the
sensitivity of our instruments to detect
these feeble signals from the cosmos and
they don't have to deal with you know on
the semiconductor fabric uh Factory in
Santa Clara California they have to deal
with like you know meteorites and
National things like coming into the
laboratory it's a clean room it's
pristine they can control everything
about it right we can't control the
cosmos and the cosmos is literally
littered with particles of Schmutz of
failed planets asteroids
meteoroids things that didn't coalesce
to make either the Earth the moon the
planet Jupiter or its moons or get
sucked into them and make craters on
them etc etc the rest of it is falling
and it comes in a power Spectrum there's
very few thank God chicksalub-sized you
know impact uh or you know progenitors
that will take out all life on Earth but
there's extremely large number of tiny
dust particles and microscopic grains
and then there's a fair number of
intermediate-sized particles
it turns out this little guy here is um
is the end product of a collapsing star
that explodes in what's called a
supernoma type 2 supernova so Stars
spend most of their life using helium
nuclei protons into
um uh and neutrons into helium uh nuclei
and then from there can make other
things like beryllium and briefly make
beryllium and carbon nitrogen oxygen all
the way up until it tries to make iron
and nickel iron and nickel are
endothermic it takes more energy than
gets liberated to make an atom of iron
when that happens there's no longer
enough heat supplying pressure to resist
the gravitational collapse of the
material that was produced earlier so
the star form is going to goes inside
out that's how scientists discovered
helium was discovered on the sun I don't
know did you know that's why it's called
helium yeah they went there at night and
oh well done they went there at night no
helium means Helios is the god of the
sun it was discovered in its Spectrum
from observations of the telescope like
150 years ago it wasn't discovered like
when uh oxygen and you know Iron was
discovered
um so it's only a relatively recent
Comer to the pure activity the helium
came after oxygen oh no first first
Hydrogen forms into helium so that's the
first thing that forms no in terms of
discoveries oh yeah after oxygen yeah I
think Priestly and yeah and others does
Dalton discovered it in the 1700s now
helium was really only discovered from
the spectrum of looking at the sun and
seeing the weird Atomic absorption and
uh called frownhofer lines in the Solar
Spectrum
so but when it tries to make iron
there's no longer any leftover heat in
other words there's heat left over from
fusing as you know the son of a plasma
physicist he fused to uh he a
hydrogenuclide you get excess energy
plus you get helium so that's why Fusion
Energy could be the energy source of the
future and always will be no no
hopefully it'll come much sooner than
that and so doing trying to make iron it
takes more energy doesn't give off
enough energy to Star collapses explodes
and what does it spray out into the you
know Cosmic interstellar medium it
sprays out the last thing it made which
is that stuff luckily for us because
some of that coalesced and made the core
of the earth onto which the lighter like
silica and carbon and the dirt and the
crust of the earth were formed and some
of that made its way to the crust the
Iron Man its way of the crust some of
that your mother ate and synthesized
hemoglobin molecules and hemoglobin has
iron particles in it so quite amazing uh
substance without it you know we
wouldn't have a red blood we wouldn't
exist as we are is this a very long
complicated mom joke
I I've done enough dad jokes my quarters
up
um so I'm taking this this object uh you
know seriously there's not all of it
gets bound up in a planet in fact
forming planets is very inefficient
um and so there's a lot of Schmutz left
over some of which gets in the way of
our telescopes looking back to the
beginning of time and some of those
molecules like iron is used in compass
needles right they're magnetized and
magnetic fields in our galaxy can align
them and make the exact polarization
pattern that we're looking for as if the
compass needles get all aligned that's
like the polarization of of the Dust
grain it's like that filter that
polarizing filter that means light
polarized like this will get absorbed
and light polarized like this will go
through so it's absorbing it's making
100 polarized light out of an initially
unpolarized light source and that's what
happened and what we ended up claiming
we on on March 17th and I'm sure if you
were there you might remember this at
the Harvard Center for astrophysics
there was an announcement there were
like three or four Nobel Prize winners
in the audience and the bicep 2 team
which I was no longer leading I was
still a member of it in fact in the
announcement the first person they
mentioned besides you know thank you you
all for being here it was me and my team
at UC San Diego although I wasn't
invited to go to the press conference uh
because that are very complicated yes
exactly
um it's a little school up there in the
Cambridge area
um and so uh they ended up making this
announcement that we had discovered the
aftershocks of inflation we had detected
the gravitational waves shaking up the
CMB and on that day past Lex Friedman
podcast back when it was called
artificial intelligence Max tagmark said
goodbye Universe hello Multiverse and
hello Nobel Prize
see he saw that as confirmatory evidence
not only of inflation not only of
gravitational waves but of the
Multiverse goodbye Universe hello
Multiverse uh Multiverse is a natural
consequence consequence of inflation yes
according to its prominent you know
supporters yeah uh yeah and of course
leave the Poetry to Max which uh he does
masterfully okay
so that the excitement was there I mean
maybe
the initial heartbreak for you is there
too that's that's some of the darker
moments you're going through but broadly
for the space of science there's
excitement there huge assignment and and
I often note that this is a problem in
what I call you know the science media
complex because oftentimes you'll see
things like pass guess air Seeger
Venus life you know exists and that will
be really I mean it's fascinating right
and with the work that she's doing or
her colleagues are doing uh or Clara
who's on your show as well and
that will be on front page New York
Times Boston Globe San Diego Union
Tribune it'll be above the fold make
headlines around the world and then six
months 12 months later is it the case
for us retraction page c17 of the
Saturday edition that nobody reads you
know and underneath the personal
so we have a problem in science that the
you know if it if it if it explodes it
leads you know and we get this huge
Fanfare and this is not unique to my
experiment this happened with the
earlier discovery of so-called um
Martian life uh of discovered in
Antarctica
um which was announced after peer review
we weren't peer reviewed at the point
when we made the announcement we had a
press conference and there are other
reasons that the team leaders felt it
was important to do that so that we
don't get scooped by a referee who's
unethical we thought we had done
everything right but that's confirmation
there's like levels to this yeah there's
many levels and there were people you
know me warning about how it would be
interpreted and wanting to also make
sure that we put all the data out
including the maps which we still
haven't released and
um so there were a lot of reasons to be
skeptical but the Audi the the the
public never knows this yeah I think
it's so I've made a rule that if I am
ever in charge of you know Doling out
large amounts of science funding that
when you you should keep kind of an
option in other words you should have
money for public the city it's fine have
money for your press conference but hold
in reserve in a bond to be used
hopefully never but if it's to be used
an equal fund for the retraction if it
should occur so you would like to see
because that's a big part of
transparency is the is the
to me in the space of science at least
that's as beautiful because it reveals
the it's like it's uh it does a great
story there's a there's an excitement
there's uh Humanity there so there's a
climax of the Triumph but there's also
climax to the like the disappointment at
the end because that also eventually
leads to Triumph again that sets up
that's the drama that sets up the
Triumph like with Andrew Wiles moving
from us last uh from us theorem I guess
it's not the last name whatever the is
like the the ups and downs of that the
roller coaster the whole thing should be
done in science that is science and when
we don't do that then we cultivate this
aura that excludes other scientists
often from minorities or women that you
have to be eins like Einstein came out
of the womb and he was just like this
guy with like Curly no he wasn't he was
he wasn't bad at math I was all that's
all nonsense but he said that he you
know when he said he attributed his
success to Lex he said I never asked my
dad what happened when I ran alongside a
light beam as a kid and thank God I
didn't because had I he would have told
me the best answer of the day which by
the way you know he would create 20
years later as a 26 year old in in the
patent office obviously in Switzerland
and in so doing by delaying when he
asked these questions he said I
approached it with the intellect of a
mature scientist not a little kid and I
wouldn't have accepted the same
explanation so sometimes assuming that
scientists are infallible inevitable uh
omniscient you know being I think that
really does a disservice Jim Gates said
you know he's like Einstein wasn't
always Einstein and we cultivate this
mystery and Allure at our Peril because
we're humans until we have artificial
Einstein which I don't think will ever
exist